our good friend uh rich eisen who's
joining us live
from indianapolis hi rich eisen
gents how are you doing rich how's it
going you're doing great how's the
weather in indy is it cold yet uh well
yesterday it was a nice warm 60 degrees
today's slight gray sky little flurries
high 30s but
it is not dampening any spirits here
it's uh the combine is being run as you
know that bubble
got pierced a couple weeks ago where
they were planning on it's pretty well
about two weeks ago there was a boycott
because they were going to bubble
everybody up about an hour ago the
league just sent out a
a memo that uh that they're that all the
covered uh protocols with the players
association have been suspended yeah so
it's kind of crazy um but
you know everybody um is walking around
town like it's
like it's uh like it used to be and um
you know restaurants are full
uh a bar last night i snuck into because
i heard the house band a great house
band called kenny pickett's little hands
they were terrific stupid um
and
uh
that was the house band they're still
playing that tune all day today guys
yeah it seems like that the tune we're
here that's been the biggest story
though there's the league lifting the
protocols and then the kenny pickett's
eight and a half inches was he playing
the ukulele instead of a full-size
guitar
it's just an eight and a half inch hands
uh
so there's that and now you know i mean
i'm now armed for the lack of better
phrase that all these stats for
tonight's
uh
workouts quarterbacks that
that only uh there are no starters in
the nfl um with hands that small um and
like goff's nine-inch hands and
um joe burrows nine-inch hands those are
some of the smallest hands the last i
think
guy drafted in the first round with
hands that small was michael vick
um and certainly didn't seem to you know
bother him in in pittsburgh pa where
it's you know kind of cold and inclement
i i i don't know what to make of it but
i told you guys and i say this like no
you said it a while ago yeah yeah i said
like a month and a half ago that we're
going to be talking about kenny
pickett's hand
and uh here we are eight and a half
because apparently he was doing hand
exercises
um you know so what were they like they
were even smaller like a couple weeks
ago i don't know about i don't know what
they are i don't even know what a hand
exercise a stretching hand exercise
could possibly be
and uh we'll see what happens tonight
he's he's out there matt corral will not
be
throwing this evening um he is still on
the
back end of the four to six weeks of the
injury that he suffered in his bowl game
so they're gonna try and
avoid any problems
uh he will not be throwing tonight malik
willis i'm very much looking forward to
seeing him
the auburn transfer transfer to liberty
seeing what he looks like tonight
um there's a great video of this uh of
the young male 1
a a
a video that's going viral
uh that somebody spotted
yesterday
malik willis across the street as they
were having
um i guess a journalist a reporter
having lunch saw through the window
malik willis um stopping on a street
corner
with with his bag open like his suitcase
open and it looks like he handed
a hat like one of the hats that they
have here for the prospects um like a
like a winter hat he handed it to
somebody who was on the street um
um you know a homeless person on the
street
and
that is
something that everybody's talking about
today about you know character issues
and who's of high character or not
and um so that's another thing that
we'll be talking about here today is i
guess malik willis's heart
um those are those are the three guys at
the top of the quarterback chart uh
carson strong he's a guy that that i
liked a lot coming into the off season
out of nevada big strong
capable quarterback didn't have the best
senior bull turn and a lot of people
were kind of down on him what what have
you heard about him uh and and what are
you looking forward to seeing from him
because he's going to have the strongest
arm of anybody tonight
well i mean i i i would hope so i mean
his last name right i mean so um
you just i i don't know you know like
there's
there's the first tier of guys i mean
daniel jeremiah got his top 100
um because he doesn't really you know
mayok what he used to do is he used to
take
each player uh each position group and
have a top five
uh prospects at each position group and
that's what i would be given going into
the combine from the chief
talent evaluator of the broadcast dj
doesn't do that he has his top 100
and of the top 50
um
there's only two quarterbacks in it
i mean corral i think might crack it at
some point but
um there's just there's wilson and
there's picket
and you know none in his top twenty
so really the the biggest if you will
major upside prospects we're gonna see
tonight
um
are wideouts that's who you're gonna see
and that's you know that's a deep group
that we're gonna see tonight uh sam
howell of um
north carolina is not gonna work out i
mean like he's not gonna run or jump or
anything like that but he's going to
sling it
so
you know i i don't know who's going to
come to the floor the cincinnati kid
ritter is going to be out there tonight
by the way he has 10 inch hands and
fumbled over 30 times in his career in
cincinnati so who the hell knows right
like well make sure make sure just to if
you would like tonight i'll give you
i'll give you the okay to do this just
just mention during your broadcast that
that ryan leaf had ten and a half inch
hands
you know what i can do that how many
times did you fumble at washington state
not not many i fumbled a lot in the nfl
well i had i had derek thomas and reggie
white and bruce smith chasing me that
was a big reason why
yeah that'll do it you know what those
are what we call extenuating
circumstances
yes we we call them very large variables
so again like that's part of the
conversation tonight you're gonna see
tight ends i don't think there's anybody
that's really you know lighting it up
from that position group um and then
there's the quarterbacks we are going to
see but it's really the wide outs
tonight
uh that everyone is excited about
um because those are the guys who as you
know the last couple of years there's
been some generationally brilliant
rookie campaigns like justin jefferson
and now
jamar chase and then of course you know
one thing that we will be hammering on
the broadcast tonight that you're going
to hear
is that this is a a a draft of depth
meaning
third fourth fifth round picks
can really blossom that there's a lot of
depth at positions and so
we will certainly tonight with wide
receivers be playing a ton of cooper cup
video you know a third rounder who winds
up being a super bowl mvp
that's the sort of material and that's
the interesting thing too is you know
the rams as you know aft a lot of their
picks but not for days two or three
and so
this is a deep draft in that respect
like if you want alignment if you're at
the top of this draft and you need
someone to protect the quarterback or go
chase down the quarterback
you're in luck if you need a quarterback
not so much
um unless you really just fall in love
with one of the guys that are available
and you just go for it
but uh brockman i think
um
the your bet with tj jefferson uh had a
final nail put in that coffin box eight
and a half inch hammer
um that hand will hopefully hold an
eight an eight and a half inch
hand will be able to hold a hammer to
nail that coffin shut rich more
importantly though i'm worried about
your hands i don't want the mic fumbling
out of your hands during the broadcast
tonight uh have you been measured
it's a headset it's a headset okay so as
you know take it out of your life you
know uh there is no measuring the size
of my cranium
um certainly since um i've got a huge
ego
you know it's a big red flag for me it's
a big red flag tonight so it's a headset
so i don't have to worry about that but
but
what was what was one of your what was
one of your uh what's more likely for
the combine
about the coaches visiting the booth oh
yeah it was belichick and andy reed
well you're gonna get an answer to that
tonight oh
yes i can't uh would you i don't know if
i should reveal so we have a promise or
not so you've been texting with one of
them
no there's a scheduled guest oh
okay do we have a time you want to you
want to drop a time we all should be
watching
the only time that i know about right
now is uh uh giovanni the podcaster who
eagles fans might know because he's been
uh podcasting about the eagles
um he now lives in indianapolis he's
coming to the booth tonight at seven
eastern to hang out with us for half an
hour that'll be cool
um by the way how about me just calling
one of them coaches like i was not
talking to any producers i had no inside
information i just took two of the
biggest name coaches there are and threw
it out there
you're a dominant what's more likely
producer and uh an administrator that's
what you are thank you manifest destiny
yeah he manifests i know
yeah i know so that's that i mean that's
literally the conversation is how the
wide receiver is going to look
and then oh by the way uh tristan ebner
um gorilla glue winner i believe from
our penultimate gorilla glue winner i
just ran into him in a hallway
practicing his 40-yard dash in a hallway
now we're leaving are you getting tips
or giving tips to treston abner
i just did him a favor and just said
stick with the glue kid
and walked away okay but he did he did
receive his gorilla glue okay pretty
cool just seeing all these kids david
bells tonight he's another toughest
player on planet earth winner um he's
here
um it's pretty cool this is this is this
is great like we're finally here it's
finally happening
and um
and uh i'm psyched this is going to be
fun are you excited for the atmosphere
tonight we were talking earlier with
rachel uh rachel panetta came on she's
gonna be doing some stuff around with
the fans and every whatnot but uh about
the vibe just like you know it's gonna
feel different it's in prime time now uh
it's more of an event than in years past
ryan was talking about how when he did
it it was just you know an empty cold
you know rca dome and now it's now it's
more of a thing
well there's seven to ten thousand fans
slated to come
and it's a good thing tom coughlin's not
in the stands anymore as one of the
evaluators or you know may he rest in
peace al davis not here because we were
told that when the guys are working out
on the field
okay we were told they're going to play
music
for the first time during the work
wow yes
they're gonna because they want to have
an atmosphere
for the players to kind of
get into i have no idea what music it's
going to be i hope it's not off of steve
mariucci's old what
ipod nano or whatever he had back in the
day you know
you know what i mean like i i don't know
but they are going to play music and i
heard that i'm like get out of here like
could you imagine coughlin would be just
like whose radio is on out here like you
know
hope it doesn't end up like the uh like
the
uh game at kansas city at halftime where
no one can hear you speak during that
process of the concert exactly you know
what it's been amazing like you're gonna
play well here's another one too get
ready for this one guys
that they are you know inspired by
you know
uh the draft coverage
and the olympics coverage
that we have uh we're placing cameras
in the homes of some of the direct uh
participants and you know watching this
like watch parties of the parents and
family members watching these kids work
out
you know like watching their 40 and then
taking a shot of we hope a celebratory
watch party like that's coming
so
[ __ ]
well i mean the meeting is the first
time i'm hearing this
and i'm like so are you telling me this
is your first ever three cone drill
watch party
great fantasy name three code drills a
three cone drill watch party that's not
a bad one they opened up for kenny
pickett's tiny hands
um and so so is jd in the straight shots
closing the show rich
dude i'm telling you like the vertex of
vertex watch party like
guy has a vertical leap of 37 and a half
let's see mom
jump off her couch and she you know like
that's gonna be my job
is to
is to bring all this home like that that
was great it will be it will be great to
see
it will be great to see
the family
a reaction i get it uh but it
it it does seem uh
really interesting to try to duplicate
especially when the kid's not there
right when the kids that's working out
is
thousands of miles away doing it in a in
a dome
in comparison to being home during the
draft day so but but it is there are
there have been in you know in all
seriousness uh some some special moments
between um
you know combine participant and uh
family member if you remember dk metcalf
zooming with his mother
um after he had a tremendous workout
here and you know he had an injury
history and the question was should he
have come out was he making the right
decision
and the combine went so successfully he
he broke down and cried so
obviously there is an emotional element
to it then we're we're trying our best
to bring it to you if we can
you know play it to you above the music
i have no idea i have no idea what music
it is
i hope it's like you know
something a little bit more upbeat
uh not to go casey kasem on you but
it'll be really um it'll be really
interesting tonight it'll be a new
combine atmosphere fans music
um
it's not like it's not like the old rca
dome ryan no at all no no it's not and
uh uh just wanted to give you a a quick
piece of information just so you in case
you run into rachel banetta uh during
your time there fellow uh compatriots
thereof of uh she did make a a comment
today that she could smoke you in the 40
yards that was a quote like smoke okay
quote unquote okay i just know the
gauntlet has been thrown within your own
building
these brash youngsters coming into the
nfl network and just talking smack yeah
um i'll just have to take it and um
um but you know i'm i'm i am feeling
good about myself or i will in a couple
of minutes where i'm standing right now
is outside the door uh of the convention
center room that the nfl network has
commandeered
to shoot all the prospects for those
bump shots to break where they're you
know in that tube and the
lights are strobe lights are going and
contests and the is in the air i'm doing
that i'm doing that i believe
i'm doing that to uh style uh not just
myself
but also the football on a stick will be
with me in the tube here and this is
going to be great i know
just so you were aware i did suggest
that we do have
a football on a stick when it comes out
that we take a shot of a football and a
stick watch party with four footballs on
a stick in some living room
watching the big football in a stick
moment that's pretty good and i think
that was definitely um not appreciated
in the meeting brought that up
at all no
i think it was viewed as i think it was
viewed as unhelpful comment
um something to lighten up i got that
they had the same sense after yesterday
after i high fogged an actual head coach
in front of the entire uh media
group that was uh that was the dupes to
our uh to our cliche festival that was
fun yesterday a day yeah t-man just
looked at you like uh you know rich
we're trying to move this along
it's trying to pull but i'm i'm serious
like i'm like let's get four footballs
on a stick put him on a couch and then
show that watch party when football in a
stick comes out just to see the family
so
beaming with pride to see the football
on a stick out there for the drills
let's see if we can pull this one off
i'm sure there has to be somebody out
there that's like is fried up a corn dog
pulled the
side off you know the topping off of it
and then shaped them into little
footballs and put them on a stick yes
ryan did you get it you understand i
think it's more of a montana thing than
anything
but anyway that's a four eastern uh tip
tonight on nfl network so all right
buddy good luck about an hour and a half
all right we'll get after it we
appreciate uh you're taking some time
bud have fun
i'm in it all right ryan thanks for um
you and your ten and a half inch hands
uh having control of the show greatly
appreciate it you bet we'll talk to you
later rich eisen everybody the host of
the rich eisen show hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here